ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะคุณหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ก็มาเจอกับครูหญิงนะคะแล้วก็ครูเรียมอีก
แล้วใช่ค่ะที่ช่องคอมเพี้ยนสิเบิ้ลไทยนะ
คะ
สายโรงเรียนครั้งหา
ผู้หญิงจะถามเหมือนกันวันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
ค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 4 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ค่ะ
ปีพตอะไรคะข้อสองพันห้า
ปีคศอะไรคะคอต
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูเรียมตอนนี้
3:00 น
26 นาที
นี้บ่าย 3 โมงแล้ว
ใช่ค่ะ
ถ้าเกิดสอนสอนกับครูหญิงคุยคุยกับผู้หญิง
เสร็จเรียมก็จะไปกินข้าวค่ะ
ผู้เรียนม 1 วันครูเรียมกินข้าวกี่มื้อคะ
กินข้าวก็ประมาณสามมื้อนะคะ
กินข้าวเช้ากินข้าวเช้าก็มาร
แต่
มื้อที่ 1 ตอนเช้าก็คือ 10:00 นใช่ 30 บ่
แล้วมือที่ 2 ล่ะคะมือที่สองนึงก็กิน
ประมาณประมาณบ่าย
15:00 น
[เพลง]
บ่าย 3 โมงค่ะแล้วมื้อที่ 3 ล่ะคะครู
เรียมกินกี่โมงก็บอกมัน 05:30 น
05:30 น
05:30 นเกาะ 3 มื้อใช่ทุเรียนมกินเยอะ
ไหมคะ 1 มื้อ
กิ่งไม่เยอะนะคะคุย
เข้าใจภาษา
ลดน้ำหนักกี่
ทำไมทำไมกูเรียมคิดลดน้ำหนักคิดอยาก 2
หรอคะคะใช่ค่ะอยากผอมอยากกดตัวเลขจริง
งง
แล้วโอเคมั้ยรถได้ไหมตอนนี้รถได้ยิน
เดี่ยวค่ะครูหญิง
ค่ะว่ากินก็น้อยแล้วออกกำลังกาย
ก็ออกกำลังกายมีเจ็บวันเดียวก็ออกกำลัง
กายประมาณ 4 วัน
นี้
อารมณ์บิด
แต่ว่าก็ยังหรอก
แล้วจะมีเกี่ยวกับความเครียด
ที่ทำให้แบบอ้วน
คู่เตรียมก็แบบว่ารถไม่ได้ใช่ไหมน้ำหนัก
ก็ไม่ลงเกาะเราคูเรียร์มาเครียดไหมเวลา
คิดพร้อมอยากผอมแต่ไม่ผอมได้แบบๆโทรมาดิ
เขาเรียกไงคะเครียดค่ะคุณอิ
หน้าครูเรียงก็จะเป็นแบบนี้
อันนี้เครียดหรือโกรธขนาด
เครียดใช่ไหมอันนี้เครียดนะ
เหมือนกำลังยิ้ม
เครียดเครียดทำไมยิ้มหน้ากูแล้วก็
ไม่หิวมีแล้วนะ
ผู้หญิงเมื่อก่อนอยากทำแล้วเขาทำไม่เป็น
อ่ะ
เอาเห็นเพื่อน
เรียก
กายกินนิดเดียวแหละน้ำหนักลงเดี่ยว
ทำไมทำไมไม่พร้อมเลยยเครียด
แล้วมีคนบอกนะว่าอ่ะยิ่งเครียดเครียดมากๆ
ก็จะมีพี่กวนคืนอ้วนขึ้นใช่ไหมคะใส่ค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าแบบอ่ะครูเรียมอ่ะเวลาเรา
เครียดใช่ไหมเราเปลี่ยนเนี่ยเราลืมพอเรา
เครียดเราก็คิดอยากกินเค้ก
chocolate
cookies  and ก็คิดคุกกี้ 1 ชิ้น
ไม่เป็นไรแต่ทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันใช่ไหมคะ
cookie  Cookie  Cookie มันก็ไม่ผอมไง
นั่งอะไรเวลาที่เราเครียดมากๆเราก็จะอยาก
เตรียมก็จะชอบกินช็อกโกแลต
กินโค้ก
กินอะไรอีกอ่ะกินคุกกี้เหมือนที่ผู้หญิง
บอกแต่ว่ามันยังไม่ให้เราไม่เครียดได้
ด้วยเหรอคะผู้หญิง
ไม่ได้นะและก็ได้นะก็ไม่ได้นะไม่ได้ถ้า
อย่างอย่างครูเรียมครูเรียนอาจจะเครียด
ที่ไม่ผอมแต่ไม่ผอมแต่ครูหญิงก็อาจจะ
เครียด
ไม่มีงานทำ
ไม่มีงานทำค่ะสมมติไม่มีออฟฟิศไม่มีงานทำ
ในไม่มีงานก็ไม่มีเงินเอาไม่มีเงินก็
เครียด
ชาติเวลาเครียดใช้คนไทยก็บอกว่าเครียด
แล้วก็เอามือ
อย่า
จ่ายหน้าผาก
เครียดมี
หนูใช่ค่ะหลายๆคนไม่มีงานเพราะว่ามีโควิช
เข้ามาไม่มีงานทำ
คะใช่ค่ะบางชื่อครูเรียมเครียดใช่ไหมครู
หญิงเครียดก็เรื่องที่เครียดไม่เหมือนกัน
เหมือนครูอะไรผู้หญิงก็เครียดนะผู้หญิงก็
คิดต่อเมื่อตอน 2 ปีที่แล้วกินอะไรนะคะ
สอบไม่ใช่
200  2000 ปีที่แล้วเนาะ
2020 เนี่ยผู้หญิงก็เครียดเหมือนครู
เรียมคือผู้หญิงก็คิดอยากผอม
อยากผอมนะว่าตอน
2019 เนี่ยหอมพ.ศ 2020 ในกินกินกินจะไม่
ผอมเท่าครูเรียมนะ
019 ก็ไปไม่ได้ผอมเท่าครูเรียมแต่พอ 2020
ในก็กินกับรู้สึกอ้อกินกินกินและเราก็
ค่อยๆอ้วนอ้วนๆพ่ออ้วนผู้หญิงเนี่ยพ่อ
อ้วนก็แบบเครียดเครียดใช่
เครียดทุกคนก็บอกหญิงทำไมอ้วนหญิงทำไม
อ้วนก็เลยเครียดพอ
2020 ซึ่งไหมคะล็อคดาวก็กรุงเทพเนี่ย
น็อคดาวน์ออฟฟิศติดปีก of ทุกวันวัน
จันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสบดีวัน
ศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ 7 วันนะครูเรียม
ออกกำลังกายอ่ะว่ามีเปิด YouTube แล้วก็
แบบออกกำลังกาย 1  1 วันเนี่ยก็
30 ถึง 50 นาที
หนู
1 วันนะ 30 ถึง 50 นาทีทุกวันก็คิดอย่าง
พร้อมหลักพร้อมจะรกเอ๊ะทำไมเราเครียดเรา
ก็อยากผอมอยากผอมคุณเรียมไม่ผอมค่ะ
อีพีเอ็มเดิม
วิ่งออกกำลังกายแบบเล่นโยคะเหรอคะ do
Yoga  mind  mind เป็นเหมือนคาร์ดิโอคดี
โอ้เอาแบบมี YouTube ให้มีผู้หญิงที่
YouTube แล้วเราก็โอเคหนึ่งสองกระโดดตบ
แต่
ไม่ผอมใช่ไหมใหญ่แล้วก็เครียดมากผู้หญิง
ก็เลยคิดเหมือนครูเรียมไหมอ่ะพอเราเครียด
มากๆไม่ผอม
น้อง
หนูว่าตอนนี้ไม่ได้เครียดเรื่องถอดอย่าง
เดียวไงคะผู้หญิงเราก็เครียดเลยแบบหมูหมู
เนี่ยมันแพงมากที่ประเทศไทยตอนนี้
อันนี้ครูเรียมแหละ mir ถ้าเครียดก็คืออะ
ไม่ Diet ใช่มั้ยคนไทยพูด Diet  Diet
แล้วมันไม่มันไม่ผอมผู้หญิงจะเครียดนะคะ
นักเรียนแล้วก็หมูแพ้เเอง
คู่เรียมเกรียมรู้ไหมตอนนี้เนี่ยหมูหมู 1
กิโลกรัมเท่าไหร่อ่ะคะหนูตอนช้า
ถ้ากูเรียนนะไปซื้อหมูไปซื้อหมูตอนนี้สอง
ร้อยแล้ว
มากกว่า 200
215 ไหมน่าจะน่าจะ
211 ก็ไม่ทำอาหาร
เมื่อก่อน 100 บาท
180 เดี๋ยวก็คิดว่าแพงแล้วนะ
แต่ตอนนี้ 215
แห้งมากแล้วก็บางคนก็ไม่มีแนะนำเพราะคง
วิทย์ใช่ไหมคะหมูแพงก็
เครียด
มีคิดว่าคนไทยหลายๆคนก็เครียดเรื่องน้ำ
มันแพงด้วยตอนนี้อ๋ออ๋อบ่น้องจะหมูแพง
คูเรียมนิขับรถไปคะ
ตอนนี้ขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์เวลาพูดเลียมขับมอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยก็ต้องมีน้ำมันใช่พม่า
มันเบนซินดีเซล
แพงช่วยคะใช่แพงมากเมื่อก่อนเกมจำได้ว่า
ถ้าแค่แบบ
ช่วงปี
2020 น้ำมันแคบฤทธิ์รับประมาณ 20 บาท
1ลิตรใช่ไหม 1  Disc แค่นี้แหละครับตอน
นี้ 1 ลิตรกี่บาท 40 ประมาณ
ประมาณ 40 บาท
ให้คนที่ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ขับรถก็เครียดนะ
น้ำมันแพงใช่ค่ะพี่ผู้หญิงได้แล้วขับรถ
ไหมคะมีเรื่อง
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้ขับรถอ่ะไม่ได้ขับรถก็น้ำ
มันแพงก็ไม่เครียดมากแต่น้ำมันแพงอาหารก็
แพงมันคู่กันใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วคนไทยเครียดเรื่องอะไรอีกไหมคะนอกจาก
น้ำมันแพงหูแทง
เตรียมก็ไม่รู้นะว่าเรื่องที่เรียนจะพูด
เนี่ยเครียดจริงหรือเปล่าเพราะเรียมเห็น
หลายๆคนก็จะเครียดช่วงวันที่ 1 กับวันที่
แต่
วันที่ 1 กับวันที่ 16
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าไมอ่ะคะอะไร
ตอนแรกครูเรียมบอกว่าเครียดวันที่ 1 คุณ
ก็คิดอ่ะวันที่ 1 เนี่ยได้เงินจากออฟฟิศ
แล้วก็ใช้ใช้ใช้แล้วก็หมดก็เลยเครียด
แต่วันที่ 16 ด้วย
เครียดเรื่องอะไรคะ
ขอไว้มั้ยเรียน 2 วัน
วันที่ 1 กับวันที่ 16 หลายๆคนก็จะซื้อ
ลอตเตอรี่ไง
ตอนหมอก็จะเครียดใช่ไหมว่าซื้อลอตเตอรี่
ถูกหรือผิดเหรอได้ถ้าเกิดถ้าเกิดซื้อ
ลอตเตอรี่แล้วถูกก็แบบไม่เครียดก็จะดีนะ
แต่ถ้าซื้อนะธุรกิจล่ะผิดก็จะเครียดเรา
ท่าน
ผู้หญิงว่าอันนี้คนไทยเครียดที่สุดเครียด
มากกว่าหมูแทงน้ำมันแดง
ซื้อลอตเตอรี่แล้วผิดเครียดคิดวันที่ 16
ทั้งซื้ออะไรจะได้ไม่ผิด
ค่ะเพราะว่าบางคนซื้อแบบซื้อลอตเตอรี่
เยอะมากๆ
ค่าเดี๋ยวเห็นบางคนซื้อลอตเตอรี่ประมาณ
2,000 บาท
บางคูกว่า 2,000 นะ
พอผิดใช่ไหมคะไม่ถูกลอตเตอรี่ก็เครียด
เครียดเพราะว่าไม่มีเงินเอาเงินไปซื้อ
ลอตเตอรี่แล้วตอนนี้ก็เหลือแต่กระดาษ
กระดาษ
ไม่ดีไม่ดีไม่ดีไม่เอาไม่เอาไม่ดีไปกิน
เหล้าต่อไปก็เคลียร์นะรถไม่ถูกลอตเตอรี่
เนี่ยแต่ไม่เป็นไรครับวันที่ 16 ก็อีก 1
ครั้งมี 1 เดือนเนี่ยสองครั้งคิดว่ากู
หญิงจะบอกว่าไม่ต้องซื้อไม่ซื้อก็ไม่ที่
ญาติอีกสักใช่มั้ยใช่ๆไม่ซื้อก็ไม่ซื้อจะ
ได้ไม่เครียดใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงซื้อบ้างไหมฮะ
ไม่ซื้อซื้อไม่ซื้อลอตเตอรี่ก็เลยไม่
เครียดไม่เครียดลอตเตอรี่
เตรียมก็ไม่ได้ซื้อเหมือนกันว่า
เวลาที่มันก็อันนี้ก็เครียดใหม่
ไว้คุยก็บอกว่าดูแบบลอตเตอรี่ก็เราไม่
เครียดใช่ไหมคะอ่ะหมูแพงก็ไม่ค่อยเครียด
ว่าไม่ได้ทำอาหารไม่ไม่ได้กินหมูค่าน้ำ
มันใช่มั้ยน้ำมันเบนซินดีเซลแพงก็ไม่ค่อย
เครียดแต่ไม่รู้อันนี้เขาเครียดไหมอ่ะแต่
ผู้หญิงเครียดนะเรื่องเนี้ยวิ่งเครียด
เรื่องอะไรคะ
ประเทศไทยร้อน
อากาศร้อนอ่ะเนี่ยมองทั้งแบบ 40 องศา 40
องศาเซลเซียสเนี่ยแบบร้อนอ่ะเธอครูหญิง
อ่ะเครียดหรอกออยทำไมมันร้อน
คู่เรียงเครียดไหมอากาศร้อนก็เครียดค่ะ
รู้สึกว่านี่จะเครียด
ขึ้นหลายอย่างมากเลยนะ
เราเป็นคนธรรมดา
ต้องทำยังไงดีอ่ะถึงจะหายเครียด
ก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันโห
นกไม่รู้ใช่ลอตเตอรี่อย่างลอตเตอรี่แค่
ไหนถ้าลอตเตอรี่เนี่ยซื้อลอตเตอรี่เรา
เครียดไม่ซื้อโอเคแต่ถ้าอาจจะหัดร้อนสมัย
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเดือนนี้เดือนเมษายนเนี่ย
เดือนเมษายนเนี่ยมันร้อน
ก็ร้อนเราก็เปิดแอร์แฟนป่ะ
คอนโดมิเนียมเนี้ยอาร์พาเน็ตเนี่ยก็จะมี
แอร์
สมัยแต่เปิดแอร์อากาศผู้หญิงอย่างนี้ก็
ประเทศไทยร้อนก็เปิดประมาณแบบ 22 เปิด
แอร์ 22
1 เดือนเปิดแอร์ 22 องศา 1 เดือนแล้วพอ
ได้บินใช่ไหมคะเป็นบิน
บินบินเปิดแอร์จ่ายไปเท่าไหร่คะ
บาทค่าไฟ
อย่าเครียดเครียดชื่อตอนร้อนผู้หญิงเปิด
แอร์ก็สบายแต่พอผู้หญิงได้พี่โง่จริงก็
เครียด
2500 บาทเปิดแอร์อะไรเนี่ยร้อนอ่ะลูก
มาบางคนก็เครียดไงเรียกไม่เหมือนกันครู
เรียมกว่าจะปะร้อนก็ไม่เครียดนะไม่เครียด
ใช่ไหมคะแต่คุยกันสำหรับเครียดมากหรือว่า
คุณเรียนมคุยอะไรเป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะคุณ
มีแฟนไหม
ตอนนี้ไม่มีค่ะ
เงินมากครูเรียมโพเรียมแหละแฟนหน่อยสิ
กูเรียนนะคะกูเรียมไม่มีแฟนเครียดไหมคะ
ไม่มีแฟนพี่ก็ไม่เครียดนะคะ
ไม่เครียดอ่ะ
มีทุเรียนไม่เครียดแต่บางคนเนี่ยผู้หญิง
ไม่มีแฟนหรือว่าผู้ชายไม่มีแฟนก็เครียด
หรอเรียบนึกว่าจะอยู่ดีแล้วแต่พี่
ไม่มีแล้วถ้าอ่ะคู่เรียงเนี่ยไม่มีแฟน
สมมตินะคะกูเรียมไม่มีแฟนน่ะเครียดจะไป
ทำไมไม่มีแฟนทำไมไม่มีแฟนพอครูเรียนมีแฟน
เครียดมากกว่า
วันนี้เราคุยกันก็เลยเรื่องความเครียดจน
แบบถึง 20 นาทีเลยค่ะพี่หญิง
นักเรียนเครียดไหมเนี่ยฟังเราร้องฟังครู
หญิงกับครูเรียมพูดเรื่องเครียดนักเรียน
เครียดไหมนักเรียนบอกว่าตอนแรกจะไม่
เครียดแต่ว่ามาฟังผู้หญิงกับผู้เรียนพูด
นั่นแหละเริ่มเริ่มเครียดแล้วเริ่มเครียด
แล้ว ok  ok ถ้าเปลี่ยนแล้วพอพอๆเพราะว่า
เครียดไม่ดีเนาะเครียดเนี่ยไม่ดีไม่เป็น
ไรค่ะเดี๋ยวเราจะมาคุยกันเรื่องทำยังไง
ให้หายเครียด
ในวีดีโอทอดแต่ไม่ใช่วันนี้ใช่ไหมไม่ใช่
วันนี้ใช่ค่ะ
โอเคค่ะสวัสดีเราก็ไปพร้อมกับความเครียด
นะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะคุณ
ตาสบายๆๆ
[เพลง]